苦尽甘来是美好的愿望，苦中找乐是一种选择。
你好，欢迎收听苦中找乐。
我是杨航，你名在金融行业工作了15年的公关人。
我会在这个波克里访谈许多好朋友，
和他们聊一聊如何找到生活的乐趣，构建人生的意义。
《刚人波奇》，一座被无数影视作品旅行故事和社交媒体反复书写的山，
也是一段很容易被浪漫化的旅程。
这一期，我们再次请来旅行经验丰富的松鹤，
讲讲他如何在海拔5000多米的山路上，靠制养机与融服和一点林场判断，
完成这趟《刚人波奇》徒步。
一路上，有暴雪高反，简陋的住宿，也有氧气耗尽，体力下降之后，
到底该继续坚持，还是果断坐上救援车的选择。
我们也聊了错风旅行，便携制养机，高原徒步的真实难度，
以及一趟旅程中那些计划之外的变化。
旅行的意义，也许从来不在于一定走完全程，
能够看清自己的身体，接受临时改变，
最后快快乐乐的出发，平平安安的回来，
可能才是真正重要的事。
本期节目，由生派提供录音场地。
欢迎松鹤。
哈喽，哈喽，大家好。
周末旅行，又去哪儿了？
前两天，是刚跑了一趟云南和西藏，最后是从新疆回来的。
云南、西藏、新疆，整个中国的西边从南到北，就全跑了一圈。
我们不是有一条边境公路叫219公路吗？
对。
219公路的话，它在西南端，它是贯穿了整个西藏，
就是沿着西藏自治区的方向，从北到南，或者从南到北，这么走过去的。
然后云南呢，我是去体验了一下旦季期间，
就是非忘记时间段的这个，
旦季期间云南的这些热门旅游目的地，都是一个什么样的一个状态。
包括哪里？
腾冲，腾冲。
然后立江，大理，相对来说，其实我觉得还是大理更火一点。
因为大理它交通的优势会更大，
从昆明过去，高铁很快就到了，大概是两个小时。
咱们这个录制的时间是2026年的5月15号，
那你去的这个时间是？
刚好是一块三个星期以前吧，就是4月下旬，4月底。
那会还不算忘记吗？马上就要迎来5.1的时候。
对，就是在5.1前，咱们现在就是尤其是23年以后，
国内出行来说的话，它的出行监风时间段，
它有一个很大的一个趋势是什么呢？
黄金周小长假，这个时间段非常火，
然后寒暑假，寒暑假尤其是这种正日子，
因为各地放假是有不同的时间段嘛。
大家都重叠的那个日子，就是最多的，是最火的。
然后呢，你稍微错开一点，就是忘记中的一个低谷弹剂，
极大的弹剂，我举个例子，比如说咱们看11，
11这个期间很火，对吧，
但是10月8号到15号这个期间，
一定是一个非常淡的时间，技能冷却时间。
然后10月1号以前有的时候，
有年头可能会涉及到导修，
导修的那个双修日，肯定是人最少的一个时间段。
都上班了，都为着接下来要来旅行。
对，所以这个其实差异上，就是有一个很明显的一个差异，
我觉得可能你要说2020年以前，大家记不太清了，
或者说是觉得可能没有那么大的差异，
但是现在是越来越明显。
哎呀，你这个经验，大多数人也学不了啊，
掌握一点没用的技巧，
但是大家可以考虑一下自己有年修假嘛，
如果法定的年修假可以修的话，
合理合法修自己合法的假期，
然后错开黄金周的正日子，
前往前一点或者往后一点都能有一个很好的旅行体验。
是，是，是。
那这个从云南之后又到了这个西藏，是吧？
对，到了西藏，
因为其实去西藏啊，
这个想法是一个很临时的想法，
就开始是有这么一个想法，
但是没有定，
没有定说我到底是要不要这一次接着云南的旅行去西藏，
还是说五月份再去？
玩完前面这个错峰之后，
那就迎来了高峰了，是吧？
五一期间你是在云南还是在西藏？
五一前到的西藏，就是五一前一周，
五一前一周就已经到西藏了，
因为我在云南待了一个星期嘛，
就是去年的时候，
去年12月就是我上次做节目之前的一段时间，
当时是冬天，冬天去了一趟西藏，
冬有西藏，
因为每年自治区都会有这种旅游政策嘛，
就是如果你们要是每年11月到3月，
大家去西藏，
去旅游的话，
你会发现A级景区，
就是不管是节，
只要是这种自治区属的A级景区，
都是免票的政策，
从11月到几月到3月？
对，基本上是从11月到3月，
基本上景区就不收门票了，
对,
然后不收门票的同时，
去年他们就是在今年春节，
他们还搞了一个特别优惠的政策，
搞了一个叫东游西藏1999的悠悠卡，
这个卡就是在微信上，
你买一个，
然后它里边有五个权益，
五个权益，
我就跟你说很直观的是什么，
你可以兑换拉萨洲际酒店的房间，
不然住宿，
199,
对，199块钱，
199块钱,
还包含拉萨洲际的住宿，
对,
如果你觉得拉萨洲际不合你的意，
你可以把它换成拉萨相格里拉，
天呐,
然后不仅如此，
它同样就是，
我刚才不是讲五个权益吗，
同样还可以再兑换另外四碗，
然后,
其他的酒店，
还有,
使用期限是在从什么时间的？
今年的话是到四月三朝，
所以我正好，
天呐,
我当时就是写这个东西，
然后我就自己买了一张，
我在云南的时候突然想起这事来了，
我一看这个东西，
它能不能用，
就你买了，还没用呢，
对，我给忘了这事了，
因为它当时写的是什么呢，
就是七天内可以退款，
超出七天不能退款，
我记得啊，
我当时写了这个东西以后，
然后下面很多人评论，
包括群里边也在说，
你超过七天就不能退了，
这肯定又坑，
去不了的话，
你说谁能写定这个时间，
能不能去？
它不是那个，
你看咱以往买很多房卷，
它是不用可退，
而且大家会觉得，
房卷这个东西，
你买的时候，
它确实是敞开得上你买，
但你实际兑换的时候，
往往没房，
对,
然后它这个东西，
最有意思是什么呀，
就是超七天，
不是不可退了吗？
所以很多人呢，
就是在七天内，
一看自己没有行程，
他就不要了，
他就退掉了，
而且它这个产品上限的很匆忙，
就很紧，
大概就在春节前一周，
才上限的，
其实很多人，
已经把春节的行程，
都已经安排好了，
所以他觉得，
我春节用不上，
可能也就这样了，
但是啊，
就谁也没想到，
其实每年四月份，
就是属于是，
西藏的旺季，
和淡季切换的时间段，
其实已经开始有游客了，
对，游客很多，
而且,
气温上来了，
气温上来了以后呢，
这张卡在四月底，
一张卡，
就是如果你没有急活的话，
在二级市场，
想嫌疑这样的市场，
基本上能够卖到一千多块钱，
就是你啥都不用干，
只要买这张卡，
自己赚一千，
对,
所以我最后，
我用这张卡，
我住了拉萨洲际，
然后我去香港里拉，
就吃了顿资助，
这个资助也很有意思，
这个香港里拉的资助，
一开始，
就是很多，
网上都评价的不太好，
因为淡季的话，
大家都要缩减成本嘛，
但是进入到旺季以后，
刚刚我们讲了，
气温回升，
当旺季切换，
游客已经开始多了，
尤其是临之桃花节，
是在三月份下旬开始的，
其实从三月份下旬，
气葬就迎来了，
大量的机葬游客，
虽然很多地方都有机场，
但只有拉萨机场，
属于是，
可以理解为门户机场，
很多朋友，
尤其是外国朋友，
想去临之桃花节的话，
基本上都会飞到拉萨，
但是你到拉萨一般，
都是要整修一天嘛，
整修个一到两天，
而且什么当地的景点，
得去看一看，
所以基本上，
都会去拉到香港里拉，
或者洲际这样的酒店，
自三月下旬开始，
包括洲际香港里拉，
以及这一系列的高端酒店，
就开始对自助餐，
进行了升级，
所以就是，
之前买了1999卡这波人，
好多都是冬天去的，
春节啊，
或者是三月初去的，
那体验不行，
都说吃的不行，
我去离开，
吃的太好了，
你这拉仇恨呀，
说的我都有点遗憾，
因为我们这次本来计划，
今年五一是去临之，
早早就把酒店，
什么都订好了，
就等着看，
能不能会再便宜点，
然后再去，
结果美国和伊朗，
就干起来了，
哎呀，干起来以后，
油价就蹭蹭往上涨，
机票也往上涨，
最后我们把行程就给去，
去了就没去成西藏，
其实如果你的心态再稳一点，
一直去拖，
或者是有拖延症心态的话，
你拖到五一当天再去临，
你发现那个票很便宜，
真的,
对，今年的这个，
包括新疆也一样，
说远一点，
我为什么从新疆回来，
一个是走西藏公路，
然后回来的时候，
我本来开始是，
想从河天直接飞回北京来，
一看那个，
有国航里程票可以换嘛，
结果呢，
因为路上堵车，
再加上一系列的原因吧，
就是我没赶上这趟飞机，
当然票我也没订，
因为里程票你可以随时订，
然后我一看，
五一期间从乌鲁木齐飞过来，
只要不是五月五号当天飞，
五百,
这确实很便宜，
确实很便宜，
然后我就从河天飞乌鲁木齐，
乌鲁木齐飞回来，
这个也是反向操作，
对吧，很多人他其实这个时候，
刚好如果是从北京来的游客的话，
这会儿正在新疆玩呢，
没往回走呢，
就是航空公司在票价的收益上，
其实他也是在动态来核算的，
正日子他肯定远期，
他就会订的高嘛，
先提前锁定这一波人，
但临时的话，
如果他们的收益出现下降，
或者是绝对预期有问题的话，
一方面可能会取消航班，
另外一方面就是会临期降价，
这两年临期降价的情况特别多，
又是一点小经验，
这个我觉得大家有可能能用得上，
你真的有拖延证的话，
真的拖到最后一刻，
反而有可能能超着比较便宜的机票。
行，那咱们这个这次就聊聊，
在这次的主题啊，
因为这次约松和强来，
就是看到，
这一回去了叫钢人波棋，
对，钢人波棋，
这个山呢，
其实它很有特色，
本身外表上就非常有辨识度，
而且比较有名气的是，
钢人波棋围着这座山，
进行的一个徒步，
大家注意啊，
我们这里叫徒步，
围着这座山徒步，
至于为什么不能说，
我们大家都常说的那个词呢，
咱们大家自己评一评，
但是我们就说围着这个山，
绕一圈，
徒步这个事呢，
我最早听是2010年，
当时因为我也是去西藏出差，
然后呢，我另外一个朋友，
他也更好去，
让我俩成合，
这不就相当于有共同一眼了吗？
然后跟聊，
我当时出差去的就是拉萨，
他去的阿里，
阿里那个地方一听就远啊，
确实远，
对，无人性嘛，
对，而且那个时候，
他这个交通也不太好，
公路上这个没有现在这么发达，
所以我也就问啊，
你有兴趣吗，
当你去过一个地儿以后，
你就想说，
哎，这地儿，
其他地儿我没去过，
下次是不是得看看，
然后我就问，
他就跟我讲徒步这事，
我说,
阿里那地儿我听说都四千五以上的海拔了，
那好图嘛，
他说,
哎，这个反正别人都图了，
他没图，
他搞反了，
然后我就记着这事了，
然后再后来呢，
是去年，
因为其实我本身对徒步这个事，
也没啥想法，
我别看，
我也是去了很多，
这个号称是徒步很厉害的地方，
甭啊,
北内啊，
但是我本身对徒步没啥想法，
然后呢，
主要是什么呢，
去年去了一趟，
因为很临时嘛，
然后也是在拉萨，
办完事以后，
想着,
我这身体又行了，
当时租了个制养机，
制养机，
一会儿讲制养机这个事，
当时租了个制养机，
然后我觉得我身体行了，
这个,
海拔没什么问题，
这次没搞反，
就是这次搞反没啥情况，
综合来我们节目，
聊的第一期，
就是去西藏，
去诸风大北营高返的故事，
然后呢，
这个,
一看这次没搞反，
又行了，
当时票也好，
弄,
就直接出了一张，
从拉萨，
飞阿里的机票，
飞阿里机票，
就直接到阿里了，
你去之前，
一般要做一下攻略嘛，
要想,
我这个地方该怎么玩，
一看,
阿里怎么，
几个玩的地方，
渣达县城，
渣达土林，
这个地方，
对河北湖集非常友好，
所有的河北身份证，
去了多免票，
因为它是属于，
叫河北定点原藏的一个线，
一个渣达，
一个日图，
它是按身份证号呢，
还是按身份证的这个，
我觉得都写，
你只要有，
能符合它的条件，
前面比如说，
腰三开头，
那个都写，
那我也能落着，
对,
然后,
另外一个就是，
马庞英错课，
感恩波奇，
然后在之后，
就是班公湖，
当时是定了这三个方向，
就属于是，
从阿里机场出去，
可以玩的三个方向，
其他就先不说了，
然后就是，
感恩波奇，
到了以后呢，
它冬天，
虽然不是关闭，
但是它是可以自驾，
开车进去的，
进去之前，
你得拍照啊，
门口写着一个大牌子，
徒步52公里，
起点,
当时就一看，
好假厚，
原来当时说的徒步，
就是从这儿啊，
52公里,
就是绕着这山一圈，
对，围着这山，
转一圈，
52公里,
但是当时呢，
因为是，
别看白天没啥事儿，
天气上，
虽然零下十几度吧，
太阳一晒，
你想五千米的高海拔，
晒起来的话，
很暖和，
感觉跟北京没啥区别，
穿的衣服都跟北京一样多，
但是到晚上它冷啊，
而且山的牙口之间，
天气变化会很大，
容易下去，
所以冬天呢，
那个地方是不能徒步的，
开车,
开个差不多九公里进去，
路不好走了，
也怕不好往里开，
所以当时就想着，
哎呀,
这次反正都已经来了这么深了，
下次有机会来一趟的话呢，
就试试，
徒步52公里试试，
反正来都来了，
也有了经验，
这次就终于开始，
算是用自己来走一走了，
对,
因为这一次是什么说呢，
也是因为，
我觉得自己行了，
身体没问题了，
这什么情况呢，
因为在云南嘛，
云南最后一站，
香里拉，
香里拉的海拔，
其实是三千四百米，
就是如果你要想进藏，
比较舒服的那种，
又担心自己可能会有什么问题，
然后呢，
又不想浪费这个时间，
那我觉得你可以选择，
从云南进藏，
比如说香里拉，
香里拉玩的地方也多，
独壳宗古城，
梅丽雪山，
然后这个室内室外的，
都可以很多地方，
而且从丽江到香里拉，
现在坐火车，
才一个半小时，
你想,
咱们从北京出发，
是有能飞大理，
飞丽江，
或者是其他地方的航班的，
所以现在去香里拉，
很方便，
而香里拉这个地方，
海拔只有三千四百米，
跟拉萨的三千六百五十米，
只有二百五十米的差距，
就很接近了，
基本上就，
你只要适应了香里拉，
基本上拉萨就没什么问题，
因为本身，
高反是一个综合性的体，
这个反应嘛，
它不光是会有氧气，
还有血压啊，
你对高度的一个适应，
比较敏感的话，
其实我觉得到了昆明，
都会有反应，
就是你不是说，
缺氧,
或者怎么样的是，
很明显的心跳加快，
晚上睡不着觉，
头也不疼，
但是是会有这种明显的区别，
尤其如果你带着血氧移的话，
这个是能看到指标上的差异，
我之前去年是前年，
在西宁我都有，
稍微又觉得有点不太舒服，
对,
昆明那个地方，
它纸背会稍微少一点，
而且它海拔，
其实没那么高，
它海拔才2348，
对,
就是,
格尔摩会更高，
所以在丽江或者乡里拉，
适应了大概几天以后，
基本上我觉得，
再进藏，
你就可以再省去，
以前我们讲，
传统,
飞过去进藏，
可能要适应了两三天，
这样的一个时间，
你玩一玩了，
身体也适应了，
大概是一个这样的情况，
所以我这次到了云南，
适应完了这个海拔，
而且也是现在把事办完了以后，
你看,
从乡里拉飞拉萨，
它有直飞，
而且用航空里程兑换，
还挺便宜的，
就折算下来，
折人民币500多块钱，
你比卧铺都便宜，
比软卧过去都便宜，
所以那就直接飞拉萨，
然后到了拉萨，
和上次一样，
也是租了一个治养机，
现在治养机很方便，
都是带车载的，
而且有两块电池的，
治养机的好处是什么呢，
就是你出门，
不用去担心，
再去找那些，
需要供养的酒店了，
随时随地可以供养，
而且自己开车的话，
治养机很有用，
虽然很多人觉得，
哎呀，我已经适应高原了，
不应该会有什么问题，
但实际上，
麻痹大意往往就是一瞬间。
哦，这个治养机，
它大概是一个什么样的，
都给我描述一下。
大概相当于两杯，
八王茶几这个奶茶的大小，
就这么一点，
对，就是差不多这么大，
那它是用什么原材料呢？
里边应该就是，
用的什么叫什么，
筛选压缩分子，
你可以把它理解为，
空气当中，
有养分子存在的嘛，
然后呢，
它用了压缩筛选的这个过程，
哦，等于它就完全就是，
只靠耗电，
就把原有空气里的这个养给你提纯了，
提纯,
所以其实在治养机使用上呢，
它有一个问题，
包括我们现在看视频，
都会说出这个问题来什么呢，
就是,
你在一个封闭空间内，
使用治养机的话，
会导致整个空气当中的，
含氧量会越来越少，
因为它给你提纯了，
对,
但是你开车的时候，
或者说你住酒店的时候，
其实不用这个担心，
因为你可以开窗户，
那就是接一个这种，
也是像一个吸管一样，
对，接一个鼻吸管，
然后你就背着，
或者是我开车的时候，
都是把它挂那个座位那个后边，
然后接个管插那个曲垫，
就直接弄上去行，
一块电池大概能用多长时间，
一块电池如果开最大的流量，
大概两个小时，
当然这个东西，
这是为什么讲叫流量啊，
你流量的话，
其实取决的是氧气的浓度，
你氧气浓度开得越高，
它对这个机器，
就是你筛选空气中分子的，
这个耗电量肯定是越高的，
越大,
这个是物理原理嘛，
本身治养机这个东西，
我觉得算是，
这两年的高原旅行上的一个新突破，
你想吧，
以前二零年以前，
谁能想到，
我还能背着一个便携治养机，
去西藏旅游后，
那个时候都是要去适应啊，
对，那时候要不大家，
比如说什么氧气罐啊，
氧气枕头啊，
然后或者是，
甚至还有什么氧气瓶啊，
这样的东西，
我就想，
以前我们家里人需要吸氧，
它会有一个挺大一个机器，
里边嘟嘟嘟嘟冒泡啊，
然后还要填充这个一些原料，
然后才能生成这个氧气，
像是耗材这样的东西，
没想到现在这个东西，
现在这么方便了，
对，传统的这种独立式吸氧机，
它依然是在高原旅行当中，
最好的产品，
但是你没有办法，
把它便携的拿出来，
就是你只能说，
是把它放在房间内，
你比如说，
像在拉萨瑞极啊，
这样的酒店里面，
它是放着这种，
就是纯的这种独立式的治养机，
那个香里拉的游泳装也是，
都是用这种独立式治养机，
它是一直接电，
氧气流量更大，
更纯,
因为小的机器，
可能是一秒钟，
可能出几次气，
它中间会有断续的，
但是独立式的话，
是一直出气的，
包括你在像，
很多机场的这种机，
就是拉萨机场，
阿里机场，
或者是，
在感染波机山上的那种医务式，
它都是用的，
这种独立式的治养机，
因为它更稳定，
然后,
出去效果更好，
但是如果你比如说，
你要抱着说是旅游，
或者说，
适应高原的这种心态的话，
那就是，
用这种便携的，
它比较方便，
当然,
就是这个东西，
以前存在一个价格上的障碍，
因为,
有期,
这两年，
大家出去旅游会多了，
会发现有那种，
卖共享治养机的，
东西都是一样的东西，
然后,
上面写100块一天，
你要觉得100块一天的话，
你一个星期，
可能,
就是一出去七到十天的1000块钱，
觉得这是不是不太合适，
很多人都会有这个想法，
这很正常，
好不好取决于价格，
你在京东买一台，
可能134,
一台就134，
然后呢，
你可能租一台，
你去咸鱼上租一台，
一天20,
这还行，
对,
所以说，
性价比高不高，
或者说产品好不好，
完全取决于看你的成本，
你们这次是，
我这次，
就是直接，
咸鱼上租的，
就是由云工，
我上次用的同样的，
这个固影商，
我是抱着试一试的，
这个心态，
上次,
就12月的时候，
去租了一台，
当时上的竹风嘛，
就是咸鱼下单，
然后到当地，
人家直接送到酒店，
然后还的时候呢，
因为我两次，
都是从新疆还的，
上次我是从阿里飞的新疆，
这次是从阿里开车去的新疆嘛，
还能在新疆还，
就是再寄回去就行，
对，寄回去，
然后找顺风，
或者京东，
直接寄回去就行，
太方便，
对，就很方便，
也是上次是什么呢，
开始,
你面对这么一个东西的时候，
本身心事物，
我就觉得它小，
会觉得它靠谱，
不靠谱嘛，
很担心这个问题，
这很正常，
我也担心，
这次,
为什么会觉得没问题，
就是因为有上次的成功经验，
上次什么呢，
第一天晚上到了以后，
因为酒店也是带供养的，
然后我也带着这个蒸养机，
而且从机场我打了一袋的氧气出来，
第二天白天我就上路不打拉工，
打一袋氧气是什么概念，
就是氧气袋，
就是那种蓝色的氧气袋，
咱们应该很多医院都有那种东西，
包括美团上，
你买一台，
买一个才十几块钱，
氧气袋主要的用途是，
我个人理解啊，
现在的它最大的用途是，
可以替代，
看着那种氧气瓶，
就是以前那种传统的那种，
很轻的那种氧气瓶，
我是每次到了拉萨机场以后，
我都是去打一袋的氧气，
因为你刚上高原嘛，
要适应一下，
去年去的时候，
我拿血氧仪，
还测了一下，
在机场大巴上不吸氧，
基本上是，
血氧会很快掉到九十以下，
你吸一下氧，
就九十五十九十六，
这么见笑，
对对对，
还是很明显的，
氧气呢，
在拉萨机场打一袋的也不贵，
无论多大都是十块钱，
所以其实你就相当于买杯奶茶的钱，
给自己来一个安全保障，
你不管能用得上用不上吧，
然后因为有氧气机嘛，
氧气袋起到了一个后备的作用，
比如说，
因为氧气机的话，
一块电池可能只有两个小时，
但是氧气袋，
它能够保证你，
反正你省着点，
用一个小时也够了，
相当于是给你一个小时的后备，
去年的时候呢，
因为我是，
第二天就上了布达拉宫，
布达拉宫其实会给人一个错觉，
你觉得这是拉萨最知名的景点，
一定要第一时间去，
实际上我更建议你最后一天去，
因为布达拉宫是爬山，
你想吧，海拔3600以上的拉萨，
你得就要适应一下，
上来就上强度也有点难，
对，它那个爬山是你要爬几个弯，
然后才能到顶，
到它的宫殿再进行参观，
并不是说你在下边就能参观，
对，我还以为这个东西，
你直接就是能，
比如坐车，
做什么交通工具，
就能到它，
它甚至连个火爆车都没有，
对，就那个地方我觉得很适合，
开一个火爆车，
但是都没有，
因为都是弹筋，
我第二天就上了布达拉宫，
第三天我就去了日卡泽，
日卡泽的海拔要更高3800，
然后日卡泽扎什的穆斯，
第四天我就去了出风，
这几天就是靠氧气机顶着，
第五天其实我从出风下来的时候，
我决定应该没问题了，
结果到了萨家，
萨家就是这两天，
姑公不是有个展览，
叫萨家寺那个大展吗，
就是都是从那边运过来的，
萨家这个地方，
就是我一看这个很有名，
得去看一看，
把车开过去了，
因为当时刚从5200米的。
出风上下来，
觉得没啥问题，
下起以后就高反，
就是一下车就高反，
我也不知道是自己是某些原因，
还是真体是没视野还是怎么样的，
赶紧就回车上，
把氧气机打开，
吸氧,
因为当时开车下来，
其实也没吸，
天气也暖，
而且觉得从高海拔下来没问题，
出风下边的小镇是4500，
出风是5200，
然后开了大概4个多小时的车，
开到萨家，
萨家是4400，
下来就高反，
不是特别严重，
只是一下就头疼的那种，
这种情况下也已经意识到，
赶紧要吸氧，
要不然会出事，
赶紧就把氧气机打开，
坐着,
然后调整呼吸节奏，
这种情况下基本上很快，
就没什么问题了，
但是也不敢掉一情心，
背着氧气机转呗，
反正就背个氧气机插个管，
然后就这么转，
因为这两次去，
都是带着炫氧一去的，
相当于是有数据支撑，
以前去的话，
咱们可能就想着，
要适应几天，
不能多吸氧，
一吸氧的话，
可能会有氧气依赖，
都会有这么个说法，
这次我个人的感觉就是，
这些说法已经过时了，
为什么讲的过时了，
我们现在已经到了2026年了，
这个供氧也好，
或者说相近的设备也好，
包括机械，
想吸氧是有的，
已经足够多了，
所以这种情况下就，
没必要没苦硬吃，
不要没苦硬吃，
我试过，
咱们其实以前，
大概在三年前，
有一个很明显的概念，
就是人人都知道，
我血氧不能低，
尤其是在平原地区，
血氧低于95%，
就要送医院，
三年前，
大家都经历过，
那个血氧下降的，
这种恐慌嘛，
但是实际上，
你到了拉萨以后，
尤其是平常保持过，
这种运动习惯，
有健身习惯的这种男性，
到了拉萨以后，
血氧掉到85以下，
是很正常的事情，
我开始以为，
是不是血氧一坏了，
有的时候手环是正常的，
后来发现是手环不准，
因为你找几个地方的血氧，
甚至你去诊所测过，
你发现血氧，
都只有80以上下，
那就是这么多，
你说那个血氧，
就是加在手指尖那种，
对，手指尖的那种，
行，我们这个节目，
其实在开头，
就是花了很长时间，
来讲这个氧气，
这个高原反应，
大家如果今后想要去高原，
去旅行，
然后想要去这个港人波旗，
去徒步的话，
肯定要先把这一关，
要能顺利地度过，
要做好这方面的功课。
就是我们讲，
出行港人波旗，
尤其难度来说，
我就提前给大家，
形象的介绍一下，
如果你要是爬过泰山，
什么华山，
那这个难度，
可是比港人波旗高多了。
真的吗？
你这个意思，
只是说它的路线的，
爬升和它的距离，
这么来说是吧？
路线的爬升距离和难度，
基本上，
都是会比泰山和华山，
更低,
尤其华山是很减险的，
这个路，
大家也看过，
其实很难。
港人波旗最大的难度，
其实就是高远，
就是害怕。
如果你把，
氧气的问题解决，
你把保暖的问题解决，
其他都不是问题，
其他的就是时间，
就是我们讲，
为什么说是，
可能会耗时间呢？
你想吧，
52公里,
那个走是走很远的，
而且它，
我们讲，
围着山，
来徒步，
走这么一圈，
其实你看到的景色呢，
在大部分情况下，
是很接近的，
四个面嘛，
四个面，
就看这座山了，
对，大部分情况下，
很接近，
南面,
是冲着镇子的这一面，
基本上，
你开着国道，
开车过来，
你看的样式，
没有什么太大的变化，
西边,
是主要徒步的主力路线，
这个景色上，
前两个小时，
你会比较新鲜，
后边,
你就会觉得，
呀，怎么还上这边，
对，就是，
心态上，
会有一个需要调整，
你去爬这个，
其他的这个，
五月啊，各种山峰啊，
它是这个，
远近高低各不同，
对吧,
而且你是在这个山上，
它是,
有各种起伏的，
有的这个，
绕着山的这一面呢，
或者刚好被这个山球挡住了，
它这个，
其实感受还是不太一样，
对,
真正好看的，
精华的路段，
就是我们纯讲风景啊，
不讲说是，
其他的，
它的所，
带的含义，
纯讲风景，
好看不好看的，
只有说是，
从天脏台，
到不动地丁，
可能,
纯走,
也就是四个小时的时间，
这五十二公里里面，
我们说，
好看的风景，
只是包括，
这四个小时，
我们这里，
打开了一张，
港人波奇的这个地图，
我们会把这张图，
放在双脑子里，
我们请松浩，
跟我们说说，
我们一般开始，
从哪儿来，
启动呢？
好,
我们就讲，
就是个，
五十二公里徒步啊，
这个是从塔亲，
塔亲是讲，
山脚下的一个镇子，
这个镇子，
现在的名字，
叫做,
有小镇的，
因为这个地方，
每年还会接待，
像尼泊尔，
像印度的游客，
因为它距离，
普拉好岸是很近的，
普拉是一个，
可以针对这两个国家，
开放的一个，
定期开放的一个国际口岸，
所以游客呢，
基本上都会，
住到这个地方来，
塔亲,
然后这个地方，
也是入口，
和卖门票的地方，
去港人波奇，
是要买门票的，
对对对，
就是从，
严格意义上来讲，
它算一个景区，
就是,
里面的这个环境卫生，
然后门票，
组织管理秩序，
然后打扒车，
交通车，
什么的，
都有,
然后你看，
这个上面，
前七公里，
写着,
可乘车，
今年呢，
其实已经，
不只是这七公里了，
是到后面的，
是到了九公里，
也是为了去，
迎接这个大客流吧，
而且把这七公里的，
车票价格降了，
你要是只做七公里，
就是二十，
你要是做九公里，
就是五十，
为什么会有，
这么大的差距呢，
经翻广场这个地方，
是主景点，
你可以把它理解为，
是旅游打卡必来景点，
你花了门票进来，
来看的景点，
至少要到这儿，
就是这个地方，
因为这个前面，
这个七公里可乘车，
为什么是可乘车呢，
因为,
纯走的话，
也没什么太多可看的，
关键是，
纯走的话呢，
它也没什么太多可看的，
就是,
这个东西，
主要就是，
看你的信仰也好，
或者说，
你的兴趣也好，
是不是在这个地方，
是不是觉得，
是不是会有风景上的，
损失,
那其实没有，
你可以坐车走，
然后,
今年呢，
为了应对大客旅游，
是直接把这个，
演到了去古寺，
这是我去年，
开车开到的地方，
这个地方，
其实可以理解为，
是真正，
游客突破的开始了，
我们讲，
为什么叫游客突破的开始，
当地居民，
很多其实，
还是从塔清开始突破，
但是人家有时间，
你作为一个游客，
你能有几天，
在这个上面，
对吧,
人家可能，
大家戴口子，
人家还扎帐篷呢，
对对,
有的还磕长头呢，
咱们都是，
旅游过去的，
人家是可能，
好长时间，
这个一辈子，
可能就来一趟，
或者来几趟，
就是一个这么个概念，
所以对于游客来说的话，
起点,
一般都是从去古寺开始，
因为今年，
大巴修到哪儿了嘛，
可别小看这两公里，
能省两公里，
是两公里，
这三十块钱，
你还是最好花一下，
对,
而且,
其实我觉得，
你人都已经，
三十块钱，
真的不算什么，
很重要，
能帮你节省，
大概,
你想吧，
九公里，
九公里至少，
在高原上来说的话，
能够节省三到四个小时，
走路相比的话，
然后,
从去古寺开始，
到止热寺，
这加起来，
是十一公里，
这段的路，
会相对平稳一点，
我想先问问，
它这个路，
是一个什么样的路，
是这个，
铺装路面吗，
还是什么，
全土路，
土路,
对,
它本身，
其实是在两个山之间，
就是,
你看啊，
这个上面写的叫，
赶上波棋，
下面这不是叫，
迎接托山吗，
就是这个地方，
旁边还是有另外一座山，
我们走的那个路，
是两个山之间，
你可以把它理解为河谷，
或者是中间的，
夹缝的这个地带，
是从这个，
中间,
这么穿过去的，
穿过去以后呢，
就相当于是，
整个你环山，
基本上，
都是在山之间来走，
因为你走山极，
那不好走，
没有必要，
你不是来跑比赛，
然后,
这个,
十一公里的路，
会相对好走一点，
但是,
其实这个，
从这个波棋点，
往后到直车四，
这五公里，
就已经开始，
出现爬生了，
这就是，
为什么很多朋友，
会说,
要在直车四这个地方，
住一晚上，
你别看，
是五千米的海拔，
但是,
因为,
有了五公里的爬生，
后面,
体力可能会出现，
很大的损耗，
对,
如果你不是一个，
只有过往比较，
长时间的，
那么高海拔的情况下，
走这么一段路，
还有这么一个爬生，
到这儿，
可能真的就是，
体力上，
已经出现了很大的，
这个消耗，
到直车四，
可以住的是吧？
对,
其实刚才，
就是你看到这个地方，
渠古寺，
和还有中间这个波棋点，
这两个地方，
都是可以输速的，
它大概是一个，
什么样的，
住宿条件呢？
很,
让人沉默的，
一个住宿条件，
真的沉默了，
就是怎么说呢？
价格上来说，
肯定不便宜的，
当然你，
你让我住了一个六人间，
是250块钱，
你是在哪儿住的？
在直车四，
直车四，
对,
住了一个六人间，
是250块钱，
一个床位，
如果你要是住大通铺，
大通铺就是一个帐篷，
那种临时搭起来的帐篷，
帐篷一间，
房间可能是，
我也没数啊，
估计可能是，
12到18个人，
这个帐篷的房间是，
200块钱,
啊?
大通铺，
当然人家那个大通铺，
现在也高级了，
大通铺的床，
也是一个一鸣二的床，
因为这个床，
搭起来会比较容易，
直接买床架的，
往上一搭就行了嘛，
对,
大通铺是200块钱，
然后,
如果你要是住四人间，
啊,
四人间的价格是400，
其实他四人间和六人间，
其实差异不大，
六人间，
你一间房，
他收你1500，
六个人住满了1500，
四人间是1600，
差异其实不大，
然后呢，
在这个，
直车四对面，
还有一个民宿群，
然后这个地方呢，
他的条件会更好一点，
当然好，
也只是说，
是把活动宝房，
变成了，
钢筋毁凝土建筑，
专混建筑，
然后,
这种房间的话，
你比如说，
一间标签，
可能一个房间里面，
两张床，
或者三张床，
这样的一间房呢，
大概就是，
价格会在600-800元，
其实你最后算起来，
人均价格，
差不多，
基本上一张床，
都是在300元上下，
有的便宜，
人多的200，
对吧,
然后这个，
人少的400，
就反正300元，
上下这个水准，
然后他们这个，
经营模式也很有意思，
就是上面，
所有的，
这些民宿的经营，
都是由下面，
镇子上，
农户,
抽签决定，
比如说，
今年这个，
上面的这个民宿，
是你来经营的，
明年集体来决定，
那就换一家了，
就很公平，
那那,
产权是谁的呢？
集体的，
哦,
有意思，
今年的话，
其实你会看到，
指着四旁边，
是有一个，
新的酒店建筑，
就是松赞开进，
赶上波棋，
当然其实我去之前，
我还挺期待，
说这个，
一万块钱，
我也要住一晚上，
后来发现他们没开开，
确实也是存在，
一定问题没开开，
无论是环保红线也好，
还是说，
这个,
今年的热门程度也好，
还是他中间，
可能会有，
公戏的单格，
这个都很正常，
反正至少没有如期，
在今年的去徒步的，
热门时间，
在开放，是吧？
对,
就是今年，
你要是去徒步的话，
就还是只能，
住这些，
条件相对感人的，
这个,
住宿条件了，
就是我给你这么，
举个例子，
我当时，
不是住个六人间吧，
因为我，
到底也比较晚，
到了以后呢，
然后我进去，
先满地，
先找插座，
对吧,
充手机，
你的电力，
这个需要充电设备太多，
对呀,
而且质量机，
质量机很重要，
尤其五千米的，
住宿,
又四处漏风的一个房子，
没有暖气，
你这很担心，
上面会出问题，
所以一定要找，
有电的，
找插座，
看了半天，
这个地方，
只有两个插座，
六人间，
两个插座，
你想这可能不够用啊，
然后你就问，
说这个插座，
怎么搞，
能不能，
就是给我个头什么的，
给个插牌也行，
人家那旁边，
住里面那个小姑娘说，
说你找老板要一个，
老板应该，
就再给你个插牌，
然后什么插是连上呗，
然后呢，
很关键的一个细节，
他旁边是另一个，
就是有一个大哥，
那个大哥，
我估计可能也是，
都不太认识，
大家都是比较陌生的那种，
大哥当时，
满院的说了一句，
说,
这样会有，
用电隐患，
我心想，
我就一个，
手机充电器，
一个质量机，
我又不跟着烧水，
他能有什么，
用电隐患，对吧，
以前咱们在学校宿热，
什么，不让用什么，
热水,
无热的快，什么的，
这用电隐患，
我心想这有什么热，
用电隐患呢，
我也没理他，
我直接找老板去，
我说要个插牌，
老板说好，
老板这个性格很好，
你要多长，
我说,
这个玩意儿，
他能多长，
给多长呗，对吧，
我说一米五差不多了，
老板说行，
老板拿了个插牌，
然后给我献领插头，
我献领插头，
就是那个献，
它不是一个成形的插牌，
我们对插牌很熟悉，
就是京东上买一个，
一米五三米，
对对对，
这种,
他直接拿了一个，
看起来很老的一个插牌，
一个插眼板，
然后插眼板上，
两根线，
他跟着你，
两根电线，
我当时心想，
哎呀,
人家担心用电，
确实有道理的，
确实有隐患，
对,
这个确实有用电隐患，
但,
当时啊，
我拿了这个插牌，
我回来我就想，
哎呀,
万一半夜出事了，
我这幸亏住这个门口，
我能考个快一点，
我来得及吧，
对,
当然其实也还好了，
因为没什么，
这个大用电的东西，
没大功率，
但你别摸它，
对,
所以就还好，
就是反正得冲上了，
我这次发现了一个，
很有意思的细节，
就是开始，
我们讲到氧气机，
在感染波期徒步期间，
基本上70%的游客，
我们讲游客，
不是当地人，
游客都是带氧气的，
而且现在的氧气，
基本上，
大家都是用碳纤维，
或者是氧气机，
碳纤维是一种，
就类似于你，
水壶那么大，
但是比水壶，
会稍微大一点，
你可能是，
两上大可乐那么大的一个瓶子，
但是它外表，
是一个碳纤维，
材质的，
它是用了更大的，
这种压力，
把高压氧气，
纯氧打进去，
其实我觉得，
纯从容量上来说，
可能跟你背俩氧气，
但也没什么区别，
但是它小，
大可乐瓶子那么大，
重量上也就那么多，
而且你越吸，
你玩儿越轻，
本身碳纤维材质就轻，
所以,
它相当于是，
一种更先进的，
一个氧气瓶的形态，
当然我觉得，
和氧气机比起来的话，
各有优势，
它因为那个东西，
你用完了，
你反正就不要，
你就扔了，
它确实卖的贵，
但是,
它用完，
就扔，很方便，
氧气机这个东西，
没电了，
你还得背着，
是很尴尬，
所以,
70%的游客，
都是用了，
付出的氧气设备，
而且,
我在睡觉的时候，
我在六人间，
六人间四个人，
去氧,
就是睡觉的时候，
也吸着，
我开始觉得，
我这个插个氧气，
是不是有点松，
后来,
我要去承能，
都是保证安全最重要。
那我们现在，
是在往回找不一句，
就是你现在，
到了这个直车寺，
这一块，
你前面也是，
来去走的吗？
从渠古寺开始，
就是纯走了，
这一段，
大概是11公里的路，
11公里的路的，
徒步,
难度最大的是什么？
是风,
但还好，
起码我去的时候，
大多数的时候，
风向是顺风的，
就是它能吹着我走，
你不会感觉到太累，
如果是逆风走，
可就太累了，
风很大，
而且会吃一点土，
所以其实从，
这11公里的难度，
并没有那么大，
相当于是给你一个，
适应的过程，
整体来说就还好，
真正的难度的开始，
就是从，
直车寺开始了，
直车寺，
到天脏台，
这中间，
上面显示有4公里，
天脏台，
到琢磨拉雅口，
4公里,
然后,
从,
后面,
琢磨拉雅口，
到这个塑形点，
其实是不动地丁，
这个6公里标的对不对，
或者说，
这个空心母弥，
到这个标的对不对，
是后面这几公里，
从天脏台，
到琢磨拉雅口，
然后,
到这个不动地丁，
这之间，
大概是在，
10公里多，
所以其实，
真正的核心难点，
就是我们讲，
从直车寺，
到不动地丁，
就是,
这大概10几公里的这一段，
那这段，
难度是体现在哪儿了，
它是,
爬升会比较多吗？
对，爬升和下降，
下降其实相对还好，
尤其是，
后面过了崖口以后，
会有一大段的缓波，
主要的崖口，
你说的是哪里？
就是琢磨拉雅口，
就是这个山口，
这儿是最高点，
对，它是5600多，
其实,
已经高于朱锋大本营了，
朱锋大本营的海拔，
只有5200米，
而且,
对于大多数游客来说，
都是坐车，
直接上了朱锋大本营，
下去可能走个200米，
打卡拍个照，
大家点多是，
最大的，
这个体力消耗，
可能就是排队，
在石头前面，
排队打卡排照，
就是这，
但是,
你走到这个地方，
可就不一样了，
当然，其实还好，
就是它一路上，
基本上，
不是纯上坡，
就是纯下坡，
起伏的路段，
会相对较好，
中间呢，
可能就是过了天上台，
会有一点，
上上下下的，
这种小起伏，
大部分时间段，
就是纯爬升，
所以你看，
从哲丝开始，
到朱锋拉雅口，
海拔的纯爬升，
大概是在600多米，
是不是，
如果吸着氧的话，
就还行？
这个我是有，
很明显的体会的，
我不是背了，
台镇养机嘛，
这养机有两块电池，
然后我有，
能撑一个小时的氧气袋，
因为我从那个那儿走的时候，
我也是，
打满了一袋的氧气走的，
我开始，
我就琢磨，
我说,
试试,
不吸氧气，
能扛多久，
关键是我担心，
后边我，
先吸完了，
我用完了，
后边没得用，
我累的呀，
你想,
那氧气机，
加电池，
加我背包里，
还一大堆东西，
那包得10斤，
10斤,
其实你说也不重，
5公斤,
对吧,
那氧气机，
加电池，
3公斤,
那你是，
这次去的主要的行李，
是放在，
塔钦呢，
是吧,
就停车场，
你看,
这个塔钦，
这个点，
其实就是那个，
转身路，
和52公里那个点，
买票,
或者是，
坐交通车的那个点，
上面有个停车场，
我就把车直接扔那儿了，
主要的行李在那儿，
然后这次背了个包，
大概有10公斤，
应该还倒不了10公斤，
我估计可能就是，
五六公斤，
因为氧气机，
是10斤,
到12斤的一个重量，
当然这个重量，
其实我们在下边走，
或者平常背，
可能觉得没什么事，
你上到五千六百米，
那就不一样，
扔了的心头有，
所以其实，
我是从，
应该是，
还没到牙口，
到牙口，
大概有个几百米之前，
我想到我干嘛，
哎呀,
我背着上来了，
我就吸呗，
对吧,
累得不行，
那吸,
我估计四个小时，
怎么也下去了，
吸上来呀，
真是神清其爽，
尤其是，
接着,
因为这个爬坡，
那个,
开始你总会觉得，
一股作气，
后来你完全做不了，
没有人做得起，
没气,
太高了，
然后就是，
从天脏台开始，
相对来说的爬升，
就没有那么高，
从直车四到天脏台的那个爬升，
是看起来最明显的，
你别看说是这个海拔上升，
好像是从直车四到天脏台，
海拔只上了三百米，
然后那个是三百米，
但实际上，
给你的视觉挑战上来说，
前一段更难，
因为为什么呢，
就我觉得可能也是，
跟大家被，
传统的路线误导力有关系，
虽然我们现在，
基础车是建设很强，
但有的路，
它是修不了的，
所以在，
中间啊，
就是我们先插一句，
你看,
在庄马拉雅口前后，
这十公里，
是没有道路能够通行的，
就是没有，
车能走的路，
但是,
它把路呢，
已经修到了天脏台，
原来的路，
是要沿着山上，
往山上走，
现在的路呢，
就是下边，
它修了一条，
可以适合车走的路，
在下边，
会走一段很平缓的，
然后到了最后的，
几百米，
是一个急速上升的，
一个,
类似于爬台阶的，
这样的一个过程，
而之前的路呢，
是一个，
看起来很平缓，
但实际上，
也要在山上走的，
那么一段路，
啊,
所以大家，
所有人，
你看着前面的人，
在山上走，
你也会在，
跟着在山上走，
你会觉得，
下边那条路，
走不了，
后来发现不对，
下边那条路能走，
下边那条路，
很好走，
但是没办法，
也不是铺装，
全是隧石组成的路面，
因为当地，
其实,
从进山以后，
就没有铺装路面了，
全都是土路，
明白,
但今年的，
担心,
游客可能会有损失嘛，
所以,
不光是这个大巴，
可以开到，
去骨寺，
从两端，
就是我们刚才讲，
这两端的话，
这边这个，
苏营典，
和这边的，
紫俄寺，
和天上台，
就这两块，
下来,
是可以进救援车的，
所谓的救援车，
它其实是，
下面藏民，
你可以理解，
为是集体分配，
或者是承包，
比如说，
你今年，
因为这个都算，
算集体财产嘛，
今年,
轮到你家了，
你家,
反正你家也有车，
只要,
上面有救援派下来，
你开着你的车，
上去,
接人,
对，就行，
接人的价格，
大概一个人，
在一百五，
到两百多之间，
就可能是一辆车，
是一千块钱，
啊,
根据你这个车，
来做人，
来决定，
你上,
你可能，
我们作为一个普通游客，
啊,
纯生走，
从塔清这么生走，
走到直热寺，
发现自己，
不行,
我高反抗不住，
我也没有补给，
医疗点也不管用，
我不走了，
我下去睡觉去了，
结束,
我下车，
那你就打电话，
交救援，
交救援的话，
给你拍辆车，
你比如说，
你就俩人，
结包,
那就一千块钱一辆车，
你一人五百，
拼好车，
你可以，
对吧,
你有四个人，
道理,
哦,
进去一趟，
收一千块钱，
对,
一千,
或者八百一千，
这个不等，
然后今年警区，
为了快速疏散游客，
就是万一，
担心有这种，
集体支流的情况，
所以警区，
自己也买了几辆，
那个大车，
就十七座的那种，
一位客，
啊,
一下能接十几个人，
就像,
这个月月赛的收容车，
一个道理，
啊,
因为毕竟这个，
还是高海拔，
有挑战，
这么走，
对,
过了牙口，
剩下就开始，
是缓下坡，
而且,
景色还挺好看的，
就属于是，
你的心情，
能够舒缓，
啊,
能够看到，
漂亮那种，
雪山,
冰湖,
还有这种，
冰川,
台元,
这种景色，
啊,
就是,
能够,
给你的，
这个,
已经,
相对受伤的心，
很多心理安慰，
啊,
也有政治走，
然后也有反着走的，
啊,
这个涉及到宗教问题了，
对于游客来说的话，
基本上都是政治走，
因为他那个，
大巴车是，
给你开到京藩广场，
和去公司的，
你只能，
这么坐着走，
那这个，
天脏台，
有什么特殊的风景吗？
其实本身，
人家以前是天脏的嘛，
啊,
风景上来说的话，
就是,
高山牙口，
雪山,
这个感觉，
旁边你也能看到，
感而摩羐，
但是,
和你在京藩广场，
就是,
为什么很多人，
或者说，
我们要在，
折四,
或者是天脏台，
住一晚上，
核心原因，
不光是要在这儿，
补充体力，
啊,
如果你对风景有要求的话，
这个地方，
是可以看日照金山的，
哦,
而且,
因为这个日照金山，
你,
东边他起来，
能看着，
然后,
西边他日落的时候，
其实也能看到，
所以,
风景上来说，
还是比较好看的，
明白,
然后,
北东利丁，
之前的最后一公里，
那段的下坡难度，
是最大的，
就是,
你会觉得，
这个路怎么就搞成这个样子了，
而且,
确实,
你感觉胜利就在眼前，
不及点，
就在,
你面前，
的一个座山头后边，
能看见，
结果,
那个路就很难走，
难走到什么地步呢，
就是,
我开始以为，
我都已经经历了这么多了，
这个,
不是什么大问题了，
而且,
我有俩等战争，
后来就是，
我真的是，
这一步，
这么,
下来,
磨下来的，
因为,
它属于是，
岁石和土的一个结合，
然后那个路面上，
就很滑，
而且那个坡度很缓，
就很急，
坡度很急，
有的地方，
甚至是能够到，
差不多四十路的，
左右的一个坡度吧，
人家当地的，
这个,
座山头的，
都很小心的那一段，
所以其实，
这段是，
整个我觉得，
在,
过程当中，
最显得一块，
但是其实，
你对比一下，
你会发现，
好像和，
你在北京搞一些，
这种,
爬野山的活动比起来，
也没有那么大的难度，
因为这个，
人家毕竟，
你想,
人家,
换着来一圈，
围着来一圈，
这个是一个，
很多年的，
一个信仰上的一个活动，
所以,
它一定是把，
相对平缓的路面，
给准备好的，
所以,
整体来说的话，
到了这个苏宁点，
接下来，
你要考虑的，
就是,
二选一，
是坐车走，
这儿就可以坐车了，
还是,
继续走完这二十多公里，
说起来还有二十多公里，
对,
其实这个时候，
就是一个很让人，
纠结的地方，
为什么叫纠结？
你想吧，
总共它才五十二公里，
五十二公里，
剩下这二十多公里，
你要是不给它走完，
你相当于，
没走完一方，
来都来了，
对吧,
但是呢，
你纠结的地方，
在于什么呢？
这二十多公里，
从风景的角度上来说，
基本上没什么风景，
尤其,
你走到这个，
不及点以后，
大多数情况下，
天已经开始发黑了，
等于是第二天呢，
今天又快入夜了，
对,
就是,
你比如说，
我们讲从折四出发，
可能是早晨，
当然,
初期的早的可能，
四点钟开始出发，
人家想的是，
后边整个图布全程的，
但是,
普通游客的话，
可能说是八点钟，
九点钟，
尤其是，
你像我不着急，
我都十一点才出发，
十一点出发，
我下这地方八点了，
八点已经开始天黑了，
晚上八点了，
对,
晚上八点，
九点,
然后这个地方天黑了，
到这个地方，
你又想，
后边二十多公里，
纯走吧也不是不行，
你按照，
一小时四公里来算的话，
走个六七个小时，
走到前半夜，
也差不多，
你要是不走呢，
在这再住一晚上，
一晚上，
你住宿的话也不会，
这个地方也就二百，
三百,
这个水平，
再住一晚，
而且前一天高原，
这个高度你也适应了，
不会有太多的担心，
也不是不行，
那就第三天白天再走，
但是呢，
普通游客，
会有这么一个，
纠结点，
就是,
我昨天晚上，
住宿的经历，
已经很一眼难睛了，
我要不要再考一晚上啊，
我要是不考这一晚上，
我要生走，
我什么都看不见，
而且我来的时候是顺风，
我回去的时候，
一定是逆风，
大顶风，
对，逆风的话，
有土,
刮过来，
那这确实是，
如果你这个，
信用不够坚定，
或者说，
你就觉得，
我就是来玩一趟的，
我就是来旅游的，
对,
而且一辆，
你坐车一个人的价格，
是一百五，
二百块钱，
然后从这儿坐车，
就是这个价钱，
对，就是大车一百五，
小车二百，
你会觉得，
我这么辛苦，
只值一百五嘛，
就会有一个，
这样很纠结的地方，
而且,
山下的住宿条件，
比山上好啊，
你从这个地方，
你穿二百，
你住一晚上，
你第二天，
再走,
跟你坐一百五出去，
炒烙,
这个仗，
越涩,
越让人难受啊，
对,
所以说，
我们不能把太多，
设计,
什么,
这个,
金钱,
名利,
这些东西，
放到这个上面，
因为你很难衡量，
你衡量出来以后，
你越算这个仗，
你会发现，
越不一样，
所以,
就是,
如果你要是单纯讲，
纯说,
风景的角度来说，
到了这个地方，
就是到普通地丁，
这个地方，
开始,
就是你去之前，
总会觉得，
啊,
坐救援车下去，
是不是有点怂？
嗯,
很正常，
你下去以后发现，
救援车，
排了都有八二多人，
哈哈哈，
嗯,
因为我来的时候，
正好赶上一辆大车过来，
大家就全上去了，
这个车，
开了差不多一个小时，
才开出去，
就开出景区，
开出景区的时候，
不断的往里，
再进救援车，
我都,
都是去上去接人，
对，都是上去接人，
一个是村民，
也要创造自己的收益，
啊,
人家本身当地人，
这个属于是，
我们讲叫支付的一个方式，
另外一个的话，
我们其实推测了一下，
就是你看，
他救援车是从这两个方向，
同时进，
他进,
从这个地方，
就这个地方和这个地方，
两个方向同时进车，
但是在，
晚上黑的不够黑的时候，
就是,
可能是下午，
或者傍晚那会儿，
左边进的车多，
他进方向，
就是,
从清风广场进的车多，
主要是接直车4，
当晚上，
受不了的，
我就定了床位了，
但是晚上，
上去我发现不行，
不行我还是得下车，
或者说我走到这一半，
发现不行，
我走不了了，
我就下车，
所以在，
前一段时间，
傍晚前一段，
是这边进的车多，
然后,
到了这边，
基本上就是，
从傍晚以后，
8点以后，
9点以后，
到后半夜，
就后半，
晚上的后半段，
这边进的车多，
啊,
因为,
车其实都是一波车，
哈哈,
已经挣过一轮钱了，
对,
这边钱，
去那边拉人，
然后,
它也是有统一调度的，
太好玩了，
对,
而且呢，
其实我们讲，
除了有这种，
纯徒步，
啊,
坐车加上徒步，
这两种，
我们讲讲，
半徒步的方式是外，
还有一种方式是，
可以骑马，
哦,
还能骑马，
对,
当然马会贵一点，
当然,
其实如果家庭出行，
或者多人出行的话，
马的清价比就显得很高了，
因为,
你找一个巷岛，
一块儿出发，
一千块钱一个人，
当然,
可能忘记的时候，
价格会上涨，
三千块钱一个人，
所以,
你要是错过三人的话，
其实,
跟找一个巷岛，
价格是一样的，
甚至,
他还有马能够帮你拖行李，
哦,
明白,
对,
你找一个巷岛，
一个人，
也不能被三人行李，
然后,
他要顾三个人，
但是你有马的话，
这就不一样，
而且,
这个,
确实,
开始的时候，
觉得背包无所谓，
流程,
大概就是这样，
然后,
很多朋友会担心，
说是,
在山上，
住宿不好定，
确实会存在这么一个问题，
山上的住宿，
都是先到先得，
而且,
先到先得，
是一个什么概念呢？
你可能到了下午以后，
门港就不让你进了，
你说,
你去转山，
他不让你进，
你说,
你去行点，
你去京方广场打个卡拍照，
那么问题，
你坐车，
就能直接到了嘛，
反正你也不住，
因为,
山上的住宿容量，
是有限的，
那,
在很多地方，
看到这种地方，
要有领队什么的，
其实,
港尔博奇这个地方，
你纯,
去图布的话，
他不需要领队，
因为他就有一条路，
对,
他只要不下去，
你都能找着路，
你就跟着人走就是了，
但是,
向岛和领队，
最大的价值，
是帮你搞定，
山上的住宿，
他们是怎么搞的呢？
人家也有群，
我们游客有群，
人家,
一个行业的，
人家也有群，
人家山上也有人的，
就是,
可能我，
我是群里问问，
所以,
今天我在山上，
你来找我，
你说这个山上，
有没有住宿什么的，
然后,
我确定了你的行程以后，
我会提前，
把你的证件，
要到,
然后,
给到山上的，
这种住宿经营者，
去把相应的床位定上，
因为,
都是要有证件登记的嘛，
然后,
但这个时候，
大家会想，
为什么他们不搞，
网上,
预定的这种，
一方面是，
山上的条件，
确实不允许，
人家现在还，
停留在手工，
来登记，
黄,
写的是谁，
谁名,
然后,
一个证件号，
停留在这个地步，
另外一个，
就是,
如果开闭网上，
预定渠道的话，
那黄牛会更多，
因为,
你在山下的话，
你找到领队去定，
或者说是，
你存靠自己，
起得早，
其实是什么，
就是,
如果你要是，
不想找领队定的话，
你自己，
早上九点钟，
坐大巴进去，
然后,
你走到差不多中午到了，
你也有地儿住，
就是那个地方住，
是肯定没问题的，
在茶馆里边，
因为它都有什么餐厅，
茶馆，什么的，
这些,
一晚上可能一百块钱，
还是几十块钱，
也能打个地铺，
对，也能打个地铺，
或者你就纯坐着，
那个地方，
其实我觉得，
比住四人间，
六人间，
它的烈是什么，
它就是不能纯平躺，
人多的话，
肯定没法纯平了，
优势是它暖和，
真的暖和，
因为山上，
你想吧，
海拔五千米，
海拔每提升一百米，
七万要下降零点六度，
五千米的话，
十四这个地方，
海拔就已经到五千米了，
对,
都已经，
那夜里，
可能都感觉，
应该是零下的温度了，
对,
所以,
即使是夏天，
夏天的温度，
可能在山上，
能有个十度，
二十度的水平，
但是到了晚上，
一旦,
这个太阳落下来，
温度会皱降，
对,
所以这个地方，
我觉得就是，
感恩波奇，
大家如果说，
是有兴趣去徒步的话，
主要搞定几点就行，
一个是，
氧气,
自己,
对,
然后另外，
你准备两天，
还是时间更长一点，
对,
然后另外一个就是，
保暖,
因为我上去的时候，
我是穿着羽终服，
然后把冲锋衣，
直接割包里了，
我其实，
我爬到一半的时候，
我就想把羽终服脱了，
我把冲锋衣换上，
因为我里边，
其实穿了一个阳容衫，
然后还有保暖内衣，
还有一个苏干什么的，
但是,
后来,
自己泛滥，
我也没穿冲锋衣，
我就直接就是，
羽终服，
拉两场开，
到了山顶，
气温是迅速变化的，
因为一下天就阴了，
天阴了，
开始下雪，
还碰上下雪了，对，
因为它那个地方，
因为冬天吧，
它也下不了雨，
就是现在的话，
还算它的冬天，
还是它下不了雨，
所以,
这个南亚的水气，
我们看这个天气预报什么的，
你会发现，
这个时间段，
也是南亚的雨季，
所以其实云，
都是在西马拉雅山那一片，
在不断的变化的，
尤其到了山上，
山顶以后，
牙口,
旁边那个云，
一旦有云的碰撞，
就会出现这种降水，
天气,
所以其实下雪，
就很容易下雪，
对,
它就下雪了，
这一下雪，
我就,
就冲风衣倒也不用穿，
因为本身羽绒服，
也还好，
直接就拉上，
就很暖和，
而且我上去，
我还穿一丘户，
这不穿丘户，
还是冷，
我上去，
还救援俩小活，
怎么做的，
那俩反正也是不太行了，
我分了一个氧气给他们，
然后因为反正我这氧气在嘛，
你把氧气给他们吗？
对,
氧气带给他们，
就是吸一下什么的，
基本上，
就陪着走了一段，
都是不愿意穿羽绒服的，
也是泛蓝，
羽绒服放包里，
也不是没带，
就是纯穿得少，
另外早晨出发太早了，
因为,
很多人可能是，
我不管是说，
信念也好，
还是说，
他们自己想省这个钱，
有其他的这种考量，
我来都来了，
我一定要全程徒步，
它有这种不同的想法，
它从早上四点钟，
它就进来，
那时候还没有大巴呀，
你前面九公里，
都要纯走，
你比如说，
我是十一点，
我才从指德斯出发，
我前面，
已经少走了二十公里，
它那可是四点钟，
生走二十公里，
才走到指德斯，
跟我同一起点，
就一路爬坡，
对,
然后后面穿的还少，
你再怎么年轻，
体力再怎么好，
消耗还是蛮大的，
尤其是很多游客，
他第一次来西藏，
或者是来西藏，
是属于有时间有限吧，
正常人时间都有限，
对吧,
是,
港澳摩基那个地方，
地理位置，
你看着地图不上不远，
实际上，
你从拉萨开过去，
一千二百公里，
比北京到上海都远，
怎么也得花一天才能到，
对,
它没有火车，
然后它没有高铁，
然后没有高速公路，
所有的路都是盘山路，
所以其实对体力的消耗，
就是路上，
对体力的消耗就很大，
所以这种情况下，
我们不讲说，
是对高原的敬畏吧，
就只能说，
你对自己身体的认识，
一定要清醒的认识，
这种情况下，
其实它影响还是蛮大的，
就是上去以后的话，
会有这种救援的情况，
然后刚才我们不是讲了，
中间会有十公里，
是不通车的吗？
通车的话，
是有救援车，
直接拉下去，
这个很快，
假如说，
在这中间，
如果觉得自己顶不住了，
那怎么办？
消防和当地的战士，
就是有武警战士，
会直接上来来救援，
其实,
就是能够上到这儿的，
大部分已经不是缺氧的问题了，
缺氧的话，
或者是客服，
或者时间已经适应了，
顶多是穿得少，
最严重的是什么？
外脚,
摔伤了，
摔伤,
然后,
你要么就是人摻着，
人家团队来的还好，
因为有领队，
有团友，
什么的，
一块儿我去上见，
70岁的都有，
人家都能来，
这没问题，
但是如果你，
这个一旦是没有对自己，
做好保护，
比如摔伤，
磕伤，碰伤，
这种情况，
其实是随之担心的，
其实景区也是，
设置了一系列的，
这种求救点，
你都不用打电话，
直接旁边一摁那个钮，
就有一个，
就类似于可视电话，
但不是，
其实不是可视了，
就是纯电话，
有扬声器，
你会跟山下，
那个最近的救援点，
来进行一个沟通，
然后,
因为上面会显示，
是那个点，
它下面会来几个人，
我看着基本上是四人一组，
你还真碰见有人来救了？
对,
四个人一组，
就这么上来，
当然,
因为人家也是爬山，
没那么快，
也得,
你要这么，
打个救援，
估计也得一个多小时，
才能救下来，
是,
所以其实，
我觉得，
这上去的话，
其实氧气都已经，
不是最大的问题了，
最大的问题就是，
跟人安全，
这个,
是不是山上，
其实还是有野生动物的？
有的,
冬天是有狼的，
夏天的话，
尤其是，
开山以后，
相对还好的是什么呢？
一个是人多，
另外一个，
大多数游客，
不再晚上行动，
白天,
都是白天嘛，
关键是什么呢？
这个,
游客都拿着登山帐，
一人两个路，
狼看着也太也怕，
那路还坚的，
所以其实，
相对就是，
人家讲开山的时候，
基本上没什么问题，
一旦风山，
它一般是不会让你去的，
一个,
就是野生动物，
相对来说，
是一方面，
另一方面是，
下雪了以后，
你找不着路，
路是什么呢？
我们人多的时候，
你看着前面，
人走的这条路，
而且你能够很清晰的，
看着有这么一条路存在，
一旦全被大雪，
覆盖了以后，
它两个小时，
就能下满，
一个人后的极雪，
哦,
一个人后，
对，一个人，
就差不多1米5，
到1米8,
这之间的，
两个小时，
就能下满，
尤其是在压口，
那在这种情况下，
你根本分辨不出来，
旁边是悬崖，
是一个斗坡，
还是平路，
下边是不是，
会有建立的碎石，
还是有什么其他的东西，
是不是有陷阱，
这个都很难讲，
看不着路了，
那肯定是不能走，
封山,
主要是安全性的问题，
因为在网上，
也刷到过一些人，
这个很极限，
然后也有一些，
这个运动的，
这个底子的，
就要挑战，
一天这个穿越，
那早晨，
就是特别早，
就出发，
然后走到晚上，
就很晚，
然后完成了这个路线，
挺危险的，是吧，
如果你体力充裕的话，
就是,
之前也经常去越野跑，
或者说，
是比较适应这种，
我觉得，
它难度真的很低，
搞什么尽难度，
像我刚才讲过，
比华山，
比泰山，
都要低，
因为,
它不需要那么大的爬升，
就起码看起来，
没有那么大的爬升，
它是把600米，
摊在了差不多，
这几公里的范围内，
而且,
路上来说，
人家都是能够，
当地居民，
去磕长头的一个路，
所以,
它也不会说，
特别难，
但是呢，
你要说，
咱们普通人，
一天,
尤其,
你时间有限，
来都来了，
打卡,
旅游的这种，
一天行不行，
它也行，
反正你两段坐车嘛，
七点钟，
第一班大巴运营，
你就坐车进来，
然后坐到最远的地方，
你开始走，
反正前十一公里，
没什么难度，
然后后边，
开始上难度，
最难的地方，
你熬过去，
只要晚上九点多，
十点钟，
到了最后的一个，
九点点，
就是从到了不动地丁，
然后你叫车，
就是坐车走，
就行了，
基本上，
对普通人来说，
一天也没什么问题，
但是,
也挺极限的嘛，
对,
人家这个，
主要是看你的时间，
还有这个体力，
比如说，
尤其是到比较晚的时候，
或者是这个，
不是夏天，
这个人没有那么多的时候，
可能夜里，
可能也会有狼，
有野兽，
还是有点危险，
对,
就是我们刚才讲，
为什么说会有一个，
普通游客来了，
会很纠结的地方，
我们讲，
来都来了嘛，
来都来了，
这个,
就取决于一个问题，
你比如说，
你来这儿，
感儿默契名气很大，
你开始没想着，
说是,
来土布，
好像如果来了，
打卡就行了呗，
到了以后，
你发现，
他管三天，
对吧,
是,
二十块钱，
坐到京湾广场，
大家拍个照，
打个卡，
完事了，
我是不是要去下一站，
你就讲，
我来都来了，
我又花了这一百五了，
我钱都花了，
我车我也坐了，
我干嘛不，
再进一步，
一点,
对,
然后这个时候，
就很纠结，
然后一问，
山上有住宿的，
没问题，
那,
住吧,
就会临时改变形成，
就会出现，
来都来了的情况，
然后呢，
还有一个就是，
我们刚才讲，
坐救援车，
下车的时候，
就是到了不动地丁，
其实为什么讲，
大部分人，
已经开始坐车了，
因为这个地方，
是坐车的一个起点，
是,
你后边二十多公里，
那个难度更低，
你是可以这么纯走完，
但是,
如果说二十公里，
你走了五公里，
你不想走了，
你觉得，
下来的车上都满了，
跟我想的不太一样，
那这个时候，
你叫车就难了，
对对对，
所有的车全是满的，
你不一定要等多少车，
才能上得了，
所以不如干脆，
就在这一站直接，
上个车就行了，
你要想拍照片，
想看风景，
旁边先，
休息休息，
吃点东西，
然后拍一拍，
看一看，
这个,
如果是坐车的话，
就尽量在最远一单坐，
要不然后面的话，
上不去，
所以这个，
如果你要临时改变主意，
或者是对自己的，
这个身体突然有一些，
突然突然来了，
来了的信心的话，
它这个路线，
虽然刚才松和给我们大家介绍，
这个确实也没那么难，
然后只要你氧气代购的话呢，
它的挑战也没那么大，
但凡,
如果不是特别恶劣的天气的话，
好像,
绝大多数人，
只要你身体健康，
然后在中间不出什么意外的话，
也能走下来，
这些就是可以走的路段，
但是我们在节目的这个最后，
也是还是提醒，
大家这个量力而行，
对吧,
这个整个这个路线呢，
它不是一个就是，
开发的特别完善的那种，
像什么韭菜沟那样的，
这个全都是铺装路面的这种，
有景区，
对,
那个确实风景也好，
然后呢，天气也没那么恶劣，
最多你是赶上下个暴雨，
能给你连，
连着,
很多人都发小洪，
要去骂街了，
那这个地方，
它确实是海拔，
四千五千的这样一个高海拔，
如果你的氧气也吸完了，
如果你的这个，
再加上，
由于它比较寒冷，
你穿的又不够多，
身体再出现一些症状了，
还是会有危险的，
大家一定要有这样的一个，
心理预期，
不要去逞能，
到那儿呢，
好好玩，
安全的返回，
是我们的这个最终的目标，
没错,
就这个地方吧，
其实我也就是，
能跟大家补充一个，
自己的一个心得吧，
因为我其实，
从新疆回，
我也是临时决定的，
我开始本来想的，
就是从拉萨回，
然后,
因为我车是从日卡泽租的嘛，
神租租车，
日卡泽租的，
还车的时候，
我开始订的日卡泽，
后来呢，
是因为我这个车，
开的,
我觉得没什么问题，
这个车是个新车，
我提车的时候，
两千二百公里，
就相当于，
它从成都开过来的，
因为窗盘嘛，
然后,
我开了这几天，
觉得这车没问题，
我这个养奇迹用的没问题，
我人没什么问题，
然后,
我也,
看了一下，
我,
问了一下，
家里人，
五一要不要来拉萨，
来洗澡，人说不来，
我说呢，
行吧,
那我想个地儿，
回去吧，
我一看，
从,
我当时在渣达，
就是从，
结束了钢销波系以后，
到的是三个小时，
渣达,
从渣达出发，
到新疆的喀什，
河铁,
以及到西藏的拉萨，
这三个地方的距离，
几乎是一样的，
都是一千五百公里，
二十九公路，
我没有开过，
新藏公路我没有开过，
就从西藏到新疆这一段，
对,
那就从阿里，
直接开到新疆去，
在新疆，
把车还了，
而且,
还车的价格是一样的，
所以我就这么决定，
就这么走，
这个也是，
很多人可能旅行，
是会出现的一个，
改这个，
就是一地还车的点，
也可以的，是吗？
对，也可以改，
而且不收钱，
不收费，
大家会很常见的一个心态，
就是反正，
我觉得没问题，
我就改了，
但是我最后，
在穿新藏公路，
回来的时候，
我出最后一个检查站，
然后那个，
就是西藏这边的，
最后一个检查站，
人家就说，
一路安全，
我一看，
天气好像还可以，
只不过是有点阴天，
结果,
开了大概一个小时，
就是暴风雪，
五一前，
应该是四月三十号吧，
然后,
巨大的暴风雪，
我开始都想着说，
要不然我折回去吧，
我折回去，
但是我担心的时候，
折回去万一开回去，
更大,
开不回去，
这时候已经到什么，
大概什么，
这个时候，
其实已经出了多马箱，
一百公里了，
就是距离新藏街，
可能只有两个小时的车程，
但是其实，
后面,
自己心里是没底的，
后来是什么呀，
有两辆大货车，
开过去了，
我心想，
大货车能开过去，
我跟着它走，
无非就是，
开得慢一点嘛，
国道是吧，
国道,
对，那一段全是国道，
而且是海拔五千米的国道，
然后,
等它过去了，
我就跟着走，
因为反正它能把路开出来，
而且,
人家既然开货车的，
人家肯定对路况更熟，
没问题，
然后开了，
大概是一个小时，
就穿出了这一带暴风雪，
景色还挺好看的，
其实,
就是,
你在路上，
临时改变行程，
会有一系列的突发的情况，
那这个时候，
就是,
要不断的调整心态，
这个不确定性，
尤其是，
像你的这个，
所有的行程，
都可以随时的调整，
然后,
临时来判断，
怎么是一个最优的选择，
往哪个方向走，
其实都可以，
是你的可选项，
对，而且，
其实就是，
我当时就想，
说要不然我停一下，
等一下雪停，
后来想着不行，
这个雪，
万一突然之间下大了，
那可能，
就给你困着了，
对，困着了，
万一前面牙口出不去，
那,
这个地方，
已经是无人区了呀，
因为,
从多马乡，
到新疆的河安县，
现在,
就是之前，
您的叫大红柳灯，
就这个地方，
大概四百公里的路，
三百公里，
还是四百公里的路，
纯属于无人区，
没有,
这种,
我们讲，
不计的，
任何的地方，
包括大火车，
我看着晚上路过的，
他们都是，
找了个停车区，
然后,
就在那儿歇着了，
也没有什么这个，
加油站，
所以,
就是,
在出行的时候，
有的时候，
要第一时间，
做好一个决断，
包括在，
赶着波棋上，
徒步的时候，
也是,
一旦判断，
自己身体不行，
不要强撑，
宁可下车，
因为有的风景，
你可以后面来再看，
没有必要说，
一次全都搞定，
一定是，
安全,
是最重要的。
我觉得，
咱们整个这一段行程，
基本上，
聊得差不多了，
这个,
聊聊你这个，
最后,
下到,
这个东西，
其实,
我们传统的，
意义上来说，
管这个东西，叫最养，
最养这个东西，
以前也不是没有体验过，
但是,
主要,
以前的印象，
都是集中在高反，
因为那个是真的难受，
高反难受，
高反难受是头疼，
然后,
你会觉得，
公文沉沉的，
传不过气，
就觉得，
头疼欲劣，
那种难受，
真的是很难，
就跟这个喝多了，
第二天早上，
那个,
宿醉的感觉差不多，
我觉得比那个，
还难受，
因为有了，
第一次的预期了，
第一次，
第一次都进去医院了嘛，
当然那次，
还好,
就是吸氧，
就完事了，
第二次，
相对好一点，
所以,
后面,
每次对高反，
是有一个，
明确的预期的，
包括,
后面,
去年去的那一次，
就是,
突然出现高反的症状，
赶紧就知道，
拿氧积积取吸氧，
包括来的时候，
什么药，
然后,
这个,
葡萄糖，
什么的，
都会背上，
因为,
低反,
大多数都是，
集中在，
你,
进藏时间长，
高海拔，
呆的时间长，
你的身体已经适应了，
你速进速出，
其实不太容易低反，
只会是，
刚进去的时候，
可能会有，
容易高反，
对，高反，
然后你，
因为我这次，
在,
四千五百米海拔上面，
你应该是呆了，
得有八天到九天，
这因为，
网上我们说，
去拉萨，
一般要适应个三天嘛，
然后再往阿里走，
所以你会发现，
跑什么大环线，
或者是中线，
南线,
就这种，
会给你这么长时间，
但其实它会，
让，建议你，
还要再拉萨，
再修整几天，
这个人家也是，
确实是很，
正确的建议，
但只不过，
是因为我，
凭借着经验，
凭借着养鸡鸡，
这一系列，
加上药品，
什么蓝金八糟的，
这些加持，
我能够第二天，
就直接往上冲，
但是呢，
下来,
没想到，
因为,
下来以后呢，
新藏公路，
开下来的时候，
在新疆的，
最后一个，
就是,
到夜城之前的那个线，
叫河康线，
刚才我们讲，
那个叫河安线，
河安线和河康线，
是这两年，
新建了一个线，
然后还有一个线，
叫陈岭线，
都是属于，
是这三个叫，
R19沿线上的这个线，
在这两个，
就是,
陈岭和河康，
这两个线的海拔，
基本上，
还在三千到四千米，
最后呢，
会在两个小时的时间，
这就是为什么说，
R19新藏公路，
反船很难穿，
但是你从西藏到新疆，
这段很好走的原因，
是因为，
你已经适应了高反，
从这个第一阶梯，
到第二阶梯，
对，你能适应这个高反，
但是你反船就不一样了，
你是两个小时，
直接从一千米，
爬到四千等，
这个,
很多人高反就扛不住，
所以,
就是,
正船和反船的区别，
那后来，
我到了一千米下去了，
当时没啥感觉，
尤其是，
开到了夜城，
那很开心啊，
你这段路结束了，
打卡拍照，
吃美食，
到新疆，
对，然后，
从下一站是和田，
因为我选了，
在和田换车，没选，
卡10,
到了和田，
一路上高速跑跑，
按着线速跑就行，
那个线速120的线速，
路上车有少，
无一期间又不收费，
开心啊，
就很爽，开着，
两个小时，
两个多小时，
就到了和田，
到了和田，
接着吃，
和田夜市接着吃，
吃美食，
到了酒店，
衣服全洗了，
因为全是土，
什么的，
结果,
这个,
第二天早上起来，
觉得,
不太对劲，
但那个对劲，
不对劲呢，
也说不出来，
是哪儿的，
不对劲，
因为就觉得，
不应该是这个状态，
但是也没觉得，
难受到哪儿去，
后来,
到乌鲁木齐转机，
乌鲁木齐转机，
在国航学医室，
那,
国航学医室，
修得比北京好多了，
好太多了，
那简直是，
然后,
吃的也挺好，
什么披萨，
大牌鸡，
全都安排上，
还现场调酒，
上了飞机，
觉得,
不行,
开始恶心，
然后就开始反思，
我这是不是在修医室，
吃多了，
还是没出席的，
这么长时间，
没喝酒，
突然喝酒，
有身体状况，
就开始恶心，
但是觉得，
不应该，
可能就是不习惯，
前几天吃了少，
因为在西藏没怎么吃，
结果,
到了北京，
北京还把更低，
氧气量更低，
回来了，
开始吐，
就直接出现了，
我吐的症状，
那心想，
这个东西，
不应该是食物中毒，
人家修医室，
不可能给你搞这个，
第二天，
一起床，
晚上六点，
我十二点睡的，
睡了十八个小时，
所以,
基本上，
已经确定，
这个就是低反，
而且,
中间,
其实也醒了几次，
但就是吐，
一直到第三天，
第三天还好，
第三天，
睡到下午两点就行了，
晚上六点钟，
然后,
我出去吃了个饭，
吃了个饭，
回来十点钟，
接着睡，
十点钟，
睡到第二天，
下午两点钟，
这个基本上，
就好多了，
这个确实，
从高原下来，
试睡,
好像是一个，
大家普遍会出现的症状，
对,
试睡,
然后,
之前,
几次,
没这么试睡，
因为,
上次的话，
其实,
在阿里，
在四千五的海拔上，
也就呆了四天，
最纯世界晒爆了，
因为,
你涂防晒是涂防晒，
大老爷们，
也觉得，
没涂唇膏，
觉得,
也不会太那个啥，
结果,
真的就，
全都晒爆了，
然后,
这次是，
连手都晒成了两个颜色，
有的时候，
泛篮,
确实是，
会出个问题，
这个,
确实也很奇妙的体验，
像你,
已经是这么，
经验丰富的旅行家了，
已经去过这么多地方，
西藏也去了好多次了，
然后,
对,
就是,
突发的情况，
你永远想不到，
下一次会有什么样的情况出现，
因为,
突发的，
这种种类，
真的是太多了，
但是呢，
之前的经验，
是能够帮助你，
去避免，
下一次出现类似的问题，
然后,
以及对你，
后面,
可能会产生的出发，
有一个迅速的判断，
就像,
我们说，
就是,
之前我有很多朋友，
聊一些东西，
我说,
有的东西，
怎么人家能碰上，
我就碰不上，
包括,
有的东西，
可能我本能，
就给避开了，
因为,
之前有过类似的经验，
所以,
下一次，
比如说，
这个东西，
在它发生之前，
我就预判到了，
可能会有，
那就赶紧不去做，
哎呀,
这个,
还是,
聊到这儿，
我觉得，
也给我种草了，
去这样的，
这种风景，
比较,
你不能说，
秀美,
但是,
有点显俊，
同时,
也是一种，
很奇妙的体验，
作品,
然后,
文学作品，
也都在描述，
尤其是现在，
在这种互联网上，
各种的小红书也好，
抖音也好，
各种网红外，
频繁去打卡，
今年有各种各样的说法，
是一个热门的景点，
但是呢，
大家,
有这样的一颗，
向往的心，
去之前，
做好准备，
到那里以后呢，
也要照顾好，
个人的安全，
我们节目，
聊的过程当中，
我反复的再说，
再提醒大家，
一定要注意安全，
这个旅行，
这个,
就是,
戏剧性的地方，
吸引我们去到那，
但是,
希望我们都能，
快快乐乐去，
平安的回来，
就反正到最后嘛，
我也补充一个，
我觉得，
没有那么虐，
但是,
非常推荐大家去，
而且是，
能够补充你，
西藏旅行，
最西端，
阿里这个点的一个目的地，
渣达,
渣达这个地方，
我刚才也，
讲过,
对于河北十分钟，
或者说河北户籍，
来说，很友好，
因为是属于，
河北人藏的一个定点，
河北十分钟国际都免票，
但是,
它有一个更大的亮点，
我觉得，
现在我，
之前去搜一系列的，
包括旅行攻略也好，
介绍文章也好，
可能是受限于，
一系列的宣传，
基本上，
没有说它的风景的，
说它的风景呢，
可能,
也只是短短四个字，
渣达土林，
土林是个什么东西，
我想大多数人，
看见这四个字，
都是一点盲，
包括我，
之前去的时候，
第一次去，
我,
真的是没想到，
能这么壮观，
美国克罗拉达大峡谷，
就是去达斯加斯，
大家都去看的那个大峡谷，
以及周边的一系列地貌，
你要说，
渣达的风景，
是可以比它还壮观的，
我听上去土林，
我感觉就是那种，
那个风化的那种，
那个山石，
但想象中我觉得，
可能也就那么，
十层楼，
几十米那么高，
对,
但是,
它是一个什么概念的，
我们可能都听说过，
俄伯良亚丹群，
什么魔鬼城，
新疆的克拉玛伊魔鬼城，
然后新疆的哈密的大海道，
渣达这个地方的壮观程度，
应该在他们的十倍以上，
而且免费，
免费是个什么概念，
就是,
我第一次去，
我是当时从，
阿里那个石櫃和坤沙机场，
开出来，
那个地方要翻五道山，
才能到那个县城，
翻过山以后，
我们突然发现，
面前出现了一大片，
土林的地貌，
就是,
类似于，
俄伯良亚丹，
或者是，
这种,
很壮观的，
哈密大海道的这样的地貌，
亚丹地貌，
结果呢，
我知道，
你要去甘肃也好，
去新疆也好，
这种地方，
你要不然，
就是土路，
要不然，
就是,
坐周围的百度车，
你像,
敦煌亚丹地质公园，
那个地方，
二百块钱一个人，
它免费的，
往里开进去，
开了一个小时，
全是这样的地貌，
所以,
那是不用收费，
绝对的视觉冲击，
而且路况很好，
巨平的路面，
就是特别丝滑的路面，
然后,
开到县城，
中央,
有一个渣达土林，
地质公园，
国家地质公园的一个碑，
整个县城，
就在,
这个河谷里面，
你住的任何一家酒店，
只要能看见外边山的酒店，
那都叫景区酒店，
都叫观景酒店，
就是,
之前,
故宫有一个展，
叫艾尔奥拉展，
沙特的那个艾尔奥拉，
我们去看这两天，
沙特旅游区，
去宣传的那些东西，
艾尔奥拉，
那个,
很奇妙的那个地方，
我去年也去过，
基本上，
这儿的风景，
很壮观，
特别壮，
而且,
它同样有，
人文古记，
神秘的谷歌王朝，
这个我记得是，
之前,
《道目笔记》，
还是《藏地医院》，
哪个书里面写的，
好过,
没想到，
在节目最后，
还有这么一个小彩蛋，
对,
然后这个地方，
为什么说，
说它是亮点，
它海拔，
只有三千七，
也不难受，
三千七，
跟拉萨是一样的，
要知道，
阿里的海拔，
是四千二以上，
所以,
又能看到人文，
这个地方，
可以说是，
整个阿里最值得玩的地方，
太好了，
这个大家听到这儿，
如果你听到这儿了，
一定要把这个笔记，
做起来，
这个,
应该还是一个，
比较冷门的景区，
估计没有那么多人知道，
非常冷门，
连票都没收到，
太棒了，
好,
那么这次就，
聊到这儿，
期待下次，
松霍,
再来我们节目作客，
聊聊他的旅行见闻，
谢谢大家，
好,
再见,
拜拜,